let's bring in seaton o'connor who joins
us
what's going on there satan
dad dad we're driving into the eye of
the storm now conditions are getting
worse
so far the van is performing marvelously
but we're getting into some pretty rough
weather
wait can you turn the camera around and
let me know what else is going on there
i'm just kidding
wow
that was a joke you had us going there
seaton i thought so i thought so
where are you right now
uh we're
uh other than in some type of uh like
state of emergency mentally um
no we're we're just outside of houston
we're gonna try to get to uh el paso
today
which is about 750 miles
um
which seems doable i think uh but we are
gonna have to drive through part of the
storm so uh i don't know we'll see how
that goes
where is the storm you're driving
through
uh
that way
it's right if you went that way that way
yes paulie it's like that movie perfect
storm with george clooney and mark
wahlberg they could have sit it out but
they're going to plow right through like
men that's it
this van was built for adventure okay so
you're heading you're hope hoping to get
to el paso tonight
yeah if we can get to el paso tonight
then it looks pretty good that we'll get
to phoenix at a decent hour on friday
okay are you still able to go to vegas
uh i'll i'll let you know after today
let's see how let's get to el paso first
okay uh anything interesting last night
on the road trip
well that's you know i learned a lot
about texas i could say that the speed
limit is
70 or 75 pretty much on every road which
it's interesting because sometimes
you're like crossing over three lanes of
traffic to try and make your turn and
there's all of these trucks flying by
so that was an interesting experience we
had some pretty great barbecue that'll
surprise you yeah um
yep yep went with uh some sausage turkey
that was really great other than that it
was a lot a lot of driving
how's the scenery with you and the
french kid
the scenery is great uh well oh there's
one problem with the french kid he's
been vaping
which
you know everything wait not inside the
not inside the van no no no okay no okay
[Laughter]
every like 90 seconds you get a waft of
watermelon smoke
you chewing bubble gum or something dude
what is that you got some bubble yum or
bubblicious or something so uh
yeah that's been a development um
we saved a uh matthew mcconaughey
autobiography for the drive today just
to get us in the mood
for texas to get the vibe right wait you
have
audio his audio book
we have his audio book yeah that he
reads
so we'll be driving through west texas
listening to matching mcconaughey
all right all right all right all right
you better get that bad boy moving you
got a storm coming in
[Laughter]
all right well
safe travels and uh good luck getting to
el paso
all right yeah we'll update you all
right that's uh seaton o'connor and the
french kid on the road
in the mercedes-benz sprinter van i
don't know the french kid vapes